طيب حسب مجريات
اول جلسه للهيئات التشريعيه في ايطاليا
يبدو انه بدايه الانقسامات في التحالف
الذي تقودهم ميلاني ظهر اسرع بكثير هذه
المره كيف ترون مستقبل هذا التحالف
في الحقيقه
الجمهوريه الايطالي
واغلبيه ل 50 سنوات بعدها عندما تاتي
الانتخابات سيكون على المواطنين
تقييم ما اذا كانت تحالف قد حكم بشكل جيد
ام لا
وسيقررون كيفيه التعبير عن اصواتهم هكذا
يحدث في كل الديمقراطيات واتمنى ان تحافظ
ايطالي على نفس المبدا لان عدم استقلال
الحكومات لم يسمح باختبار السياسيين في
الميدان لوقت طويل
نفسها ما هي الدروس التي تعلمها الحزب بعد
الانتخابات الاخيره الاخيره
سياسيه كانت مختلفه كثيرا عنا تاريخيا ليس
انجازا انتخابيه لكن على الجانب الاخر
اعتقد ان هذه التجربه اظهرت ان الرابطه هي
حزب لا ينظر فقط الى المصلحه الانتخابيه
ولا تقوده هو المصالح الانتخابيه فقط
وانما ينظر لما يج وان يقدم للبلد وما هي
التضحيات التي ينبغي ان يقدمها وهو حزب
يعرف كيف يضحي وفي هذا الاتجاه فانه عندما
يكون هناك مصلحه عليا للبلاد فان الرابطه
نجحت في اعطاء الاولويه
لمصلحه ايطاليا على حسابي قوتنا سياسيه
وبالتالي فانني انظر للامر بايجابيه ان
تحصر تفكيرك بممارسه السياسه في حصد
الاصوات الانتخابيه هو امر خاطئ كليا